هذا الدمار الذي خلفه الاحتلال بعد عمليه
عسكريه استمرت 12 ساعه في مخيم نور شمس
تخللها اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه وانفجارات
متتاليه سمعت منذ ساعات الليل وحتى انسحاب
الاحتلال قبل قليل هنا حاله الدمار التي
شهدتها المخيم وساحات المخيم ازقه المخيم
قوات الاحتلال باليات العسكريه وجرافات
اقتحمت هذه المنطقه والطرق الضيقه في اطار
تدمير منازل الفلسطينيين الامنين هذه
الاماكن لم لم تقم باحتواء مقاومين كما
يدعي الاحتلال وانما الاحتلال يهدف فقط
لتدمير منازل المواطنين والمدنيين في شتى
المناطق الفلسطينيه حاله دمار واسعه في
المنطقه هنا نرصد هذه المركبه او المركبات
التي دمرها الاحتلال في هذه اللحظه هنا في
هذه المنطقه مركبه
قام الاحتلال بتدميره بشكل كامل كما تظهر
في هذه الصوره و يعني تدمير اضافه الى ذلك
المنازل وجدران المنازل في صوره واضحه كما
يقول الفلسطينيون هنا انه انها حاله
انتقام ليست الا من قبل
الاحتلال هذا المنزل وبجرافيك قام
الاحتلال
بدهس تدمير الجدار الخارجي لهذا المنزل
ايضا نرصد في المنطقه العليا ايضا يعني
كما لربما تشاهدون في هذه الصوره حاله
الخراب التي لحقت بهذا المكان هنا ايضا
مركبه ايضا قام الاحتلال بتدميرها في
الاعلى من هذا الطريق ايضا قام الاحتلال
بتدمير عدد كبير من المركبات والمنازل
والجدران
وايضا تحفير للبنى
التحتيه يرى
مراقبون ان استمرار الاحتلال في تدمير هذه
الممتلكات والمنازل ليست الا محاوله
لتدمير الحاضنه الشعبيه
للمقاومين من مخيم نور شمس ليث جعار
الجزيره